اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن تبريد
قارفات الاستراتيجيه روسيه والصينيه
دوريات المشتركه فوق بحر اليابان وبحر
شرقي الصين
95 وصينيه من نوع مكون من سته نفذت دوريات
جويه استمرت ثمانيه ساعات قامت خلالها
القاضي فاته روسيه بعمليه هبوط في مطار في
الصين
والصينيه وعمليات هبوط مماثله في مطار في
روسيا
ما زالت في بيانها ان دوريات الروسيه
الصينيه الجويه المشتركه غير موجهه ضد احد
وفي اطار القانون الدولي ونفت ان تكون
طائره الدوريات المشتركه قد اخترقت المجال
الجويه
لدول اخرى
وكاله وكاله الانباء الكوريه الجنوبيه قد
اعلنت في وقت سابقا لطائرات حربيه صينيه
وروسيه دخلت بشكل مؤقت الى منطقه الدفاع
الجوي الكوري الجنوبي وقالت الى الجيش
الكوريه الجنوبيه اتخذ ما وصفها
بالاجراءات التكتيكيه ونشر عدد من
المقاتلات عقب دخول الثمانيه
الى مجاله
صينيه وروسيه حلقت فوق بحي اليابان كما
ذكرت الوزاره انها تجمع المزيد من
المعلومات حول الحادث في هذا في معرفه
النيه من وراء
[تصفيق]
مدير مكتب الجزيره ناصر عبد الحق ومن
موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره زوور شاوش نبدا
معك زاورشا وتفاعلات هذا المضاع في موسكو
[تصفيق]
اول مره تقوم فيها روسيا والصين بطلعات
جويه مشتركه للقاذفات استراتيجيه من
البلدين ولكن ربما الجديد المعطى الجديد
هو ان تقوم هذه المقاتله القاذفات اقصد
الروسيه بالهبوط على الاراضي الصينيه في
احد المطارات وقيام القذفات الصينيه بهبوط
ايضا على احد المطارات الروسيه في اقصى
الشرق الروسي بالنسبه لروسيا والصين منطقه
همم المحيط الهادي وجنوب شرق اسيا مهمه من
الناحيه الج- الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه وترى
موسكو ان تواجد الغربي ومس- مساعي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لانشاء منظومه
شبيهه لانيته في منطقه جنوب شرق اسيا فيما
يعرف اوكوس يهدد بشكل مباشر الامن
الاستراتيجي يهدد الامن الروسي في منطقه
تعتبر حيويه واستراتيجيه لها من الناحيه
العسكريه والامنيه وح الاقتصاديه ربما
الملفت هو التوقيت التوقيت بعد حديث كثير
عن همم
انتظار لمواقف صينيه بعد المؤتمر المؤتمر
الحزب الشيوعي الصيني روسيا كانت تعول
عليه تعول على بقاء الزعيم الصيني وهذا
ماتم ومن الواضح على مدى يومين كان هناك
امس مؤتمر اقتصادي مشترك بين روسيا والصين
تحدث البلدان فيه عن تطوير التعاون
الاقتصادي خاصه في مجال الطاقه اليوم نرى
دوريات لطائرات استراتيجيه استراتيجيه
قادره على الاطلاق صواريخ وقنابل نوويه
برفقه مقاتلات روسيه وصينيه قامت بحمايتها
كل هذا براي على الاقل من يتابع هذا
الموضوع هنا في روسيا فيه رسائل للغرب انا
عالم جديد يتكون همم
برايه على الاقل الجانب الروسي همم عالم
متعدد الاخطاب يحاول ان يفرط شروطه على
همم الارض وفي همم ملاعب السياسه وملاعب
القوه العسكريه ايضا عبد الصمد
بخصوص هذه الدوريات ماذا عن السلطات
الصينيه الذي قالتها عن سياق هذه الدوريات
وكيف تعاملت معارض سلوى طوكيو عليها
الصين لم تعلن عن هذه المناورات اليوم
ولكن هناك الانباء في الصباح يبدو ان هذه
المناورات بدات منذ صباح اليوم في منطقه
بحر شرق الصين حيث اعلنت وكاله الانباء
الكوريه الجنوبيه يهاب عن رصدها بدايه
لطائرات وقذفات صينيه اقتربت من منطقه
الدفاع الجوي لكوريا
لكنها قالت ان هذه الطائرات لم تخترق
المجال الجوي لكوريا
وبعدها بساعات قليله عادت هذه الطائرات
الصينيه برفقه قذفات روسيه
ومقاتلات من طراز سوخوي 35
وايضا اقتربت مره اخرى من خط الدفاع الجوي
لكوريا همم
يلجنوبيه اعلنت عن انعاظها من مثل هذه
المناورات القريبه همم من حدودها في الوقت
الذي كانت كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات
المتحده تتطلع الى دور صيني في كبح جماح
الصواريخ الكوريه االشماليه التي برايهم
تهدد المنطقه باسرها ولكن تفاجئ الكوريون
الجنوبيون بهذه المناورات اليوم
المناورات اليوم كما ذكر الزميل زاور شوج
هي تظهر هناك تطور في نوعيه هذه المناورات
يشير اليه تبادل هبوط هذه الطائرات حسب ما
ذكرت الانباء في وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان
هناك طائرات روسيه هبطت في مطارات صينيه
وايضا هناك طائرات صينيه هبطت في مطارات
روسيه ما يشير الى توسيع التعاون بين
بلدين في مجال في المجال همم العسكري في
منطقه في منطقه تشهد منذ فتره طويله توتر
ملحوظا بين مناورات امريكيه من جهه
وصواريخ كوريه شماليه من جهه اخرى وتاتي
اليوم هذه المناورات المشتركه بين الصين
وروسيا لتزيد من التوتر في همم المنطقه
كما قلت الصين لحد هذه اللحظه لم تعلن عن
هذه المناورات ولم ترد على الجانب الكوري
الجنوبي همم
بشانها نعم نعم
في مصر شكرا جزيلا لكما